[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette édition
spéciale d' espace autochtone en direct
c'est la journée nationale des peuples
autochtones donc c'est une journée très
importante
c'est aussi le mois de l'histoire
autochtone et ça c'est important de
rappeler parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
la journée mais très peu du mois et
l'histoire autochtone elle a été bâtie
entre autres autour des langues
autochtones et c'est notre thème
aujourd'hui parce que si à une journée
nationale un mois de l'histoire il ya
aussi une année internationale des
langues autochtones et ça se passe cette
année
alors à côté de moi isabelle picard
bonjour isabel coixet isabelle qui est
notre collaboratrice régulière avec vous
il appelle on va parler dans des langues
autochtones des langues
il y en a beaucoup en fait énormément au
canada beaucoup plus que ce que les gens
s'imaginent habituellement oui
absolument mais en fait dans le monde il
ya 6000 langues autochtones quand même
au canada on parle de 70 langues
autochtones et en plus des dialectes
oui c'est ça j'entendais entre 60 et 70
en fait le chiffre est pas précis
dépendamment si on considère que c'est
une langue ou un dialecte c'est là qu'il
ya des disparités exactement les trois
langues autochtones les plus parlées
c'est le cri lino petit tout en premier
et line ou en troisième ligne qui tout
est dit nous en troisième mais quand on
est au québec un nom partout au camer
tout un oui absolument et de ces deux en
fait de ces 60 langues autochtones le
deux tiers sont considérés comme étant
menacée quand même et le reste sont
considérés comme étant vulnérables
alors on doit travailler fort à la
conservation des langues etc notamment
sur ce dont on va parler aujourd'hui
ensemble
le pays compte aussi deux langues
plusieurs langues autochtones en voie
d'extinction
c'est entre autres le cas de la langue
qaïda en colombie-britannique également
la binah qui si on regarde au québec
oui donc c'est une extrêmement fragile
et l'hémorragie pour renverser la
tendance quand même le gouvernement
canadien ont voté hier le projet de loi
c'est 91 qui vise la protection et la
revitalisation des langues auto alors ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle on s'était
intéressé au long des autochtones avec
les gens de la rue alors si vous voulez
on va tout de suite allé écouter ce que
les gens de la rue connaissent des
langues autochtones
ok ok alors je dis tout de suite nous
sommes ici à montréal en plein coeur du
vieux montréal place jacques cartier au
pied du centre culturel
ashkan ashkan qui est un moment wac vous
savez pas ce que ça veut dire
et bien moi non plus non c'est pas vrai
je les écris je vais vous le retrouver
mais à shukan donc est à mohacs alors si
les gens veulent venir nous retrouver on
est là actuellement et pour les
prochaines minutes
mais là on va s'intéresser à la langue
qui nous avec notre première invitée
yvette molunge ou rivette
yvette vous êtes chargé de cours à
l'université de montréal vous enseignez
votre langue qui est lindsay l'universel
montréal ad non locuteurs mais enseigne
aussi à l'université du québec à
chicoutimi dei nous la clé apprennent à
écrire et à lire la langue
oui alors avant de parler yvette
isabelle parlez nous de la landing
enfin il y à 11000 personnes qui parlent
linou au québec mais aussi au labrador
puisqu'on en compte deux communautés
innues également oui et la langue innue
comporte plusieurs dialectes et sous dit
alex on va en parler avec yvette dans
quelques instants les innus sont très
proactif dans la conservation dans la
transmission de cette langue leur il ya
plusieurs outils d'apprentissage des
applications même au niveau des
cellulaires qui existe la traduction de
livres de romans donc en langues
il nous est en fait pour entrer tout de
suite dans le car le sujet yvette j'ai
envie de vous poser la question on dit
souvent que dans les langues autochtones
il n'y a pas de féminin
2 masculin on parle d'animer et de
l'animer qu'en est il au juste pour la
langue uni mail et nous aussi fonctionne
comme les langue algonquine qui anime et
inanimé et ça n'a rien à voir avec 6 et
vivent aux pauvres vivant animé l'animé
et il ya certaines catégories qu'on peut
déjà classé dans animé et d'autres
inanimées
mais par exemple un arbre est ce que
c'est plus animées ou inanimé dans les
catégories on peut mettre tout ce qui
est arbres comme ici devant moi c'est
énorme s'est animé est une roche par
exemple ça dépend si elle traîne par
terre comme ça c'est une amie lui remet
une roche à annie qu'on utilise pour le
match g le temps pas sûr histoire s'est
animée oui on l'a chauffé elle s'anime à
eux
mais si on peut on peut dire ça comme ça
oui la langue y nous c'est une langue
agglutinant tu
qu'est ce que ça veut dire exactement
agglutinant parce qu'on ajoute des
préfixes ou des suffixes pour augmenter
ou pour changer le sens du mot cloud et
et on fait ça dans les noms alors par
exemple je sais pas le mot merci est-ce
que merci quand vous le dites en innu
c'est déjà agglutinés oui mais dans le
fond de mon merci ça vient du verbe
marques comme héros qui veut dire il le
remercie
et quand on dit des narcos maintenant je
te remercier c'est comme si c'est un
verbe transitif animé donc ça peut avoir
un sens direct - une version et l'enfant
vous pouvez me remercier c'est un autre
produit
merci alors ce serait quoi le mien ça
serait quoi monteynard quand même
d'accord dinars comme d'accord vous
enseignez donc à l'université de
montréal vous le disiez vos locuteurs
sont beaucoup non autochtones oui la
plupart des étudiants qui sont à
l'université sont des non autochtones
qui viennent de plusieurs programmes de
un peu aussi d'autres universités oui
mais par contre et ça c'est important la
gale enseignements mais il ya aussi la
transmission et ça pour vous c'est un
enjeu qui est primordial parce que si on
veut que la langue vive il faut
l'enseigner il faut attirer les jeunes
tout ça les intéressait à la parler
qu'est ce que vous faites vous
développez des outils pour les jeunes
avec les cours que je donne en ce moment
à l'universel mariage de fabrique du
matériel
et comme je vise aussi les des enfants
qui ne parlent plus la langue je veux
que ce matériel l'aude leur servent
aussi à apprendre à écrire et à lire la
langue
oui il y en a beaucoup qui ne la parle
plus parce qu'ils l'apprennent à l'école
les premières années d'études au
primaire on étudie la langue déjà dans
plusieurs communautés la langue non
mais plus parler mais ça sent bon on
dirait que ça s'envoie vers l'est
maintenant
maintenant c'est on dirait que c'est
rendu maintenant comme un gant et
conduit marois et qu'en est il entre les
communautés est ce que par exemple une
ligne de maquillage peut comprendre unis
nous qui veut s'exprimer à une angie
coup c'est un peu comme en français
c'est bien tu en parles les acadiens qui
vont parler est ce que les gens de
montréal vont comprendre il faut avoir
c'est exactement les mémos c'est pour
nous c'est différent
un peu comme paris et montréal c'est
différent ah oui donc les dialectes
cesser les mots sur 20 mais il ya des
régionalismes aussi qu'ils sont unis et
dans certains autres comme louis yvette
est ce que vous avez de l'espoir
justement la jeunesse pour continuer à
apprendre et à transmettre la langue
oui j'ai beaucoup d'espoir parce qu'il
ya quand même des enseignants qui sont
dédiées qui veulent vraiment que la
transmission se fasse et c'est vraiment
mon travail c'est aussi de faire de pub
la conscientisation auprès des locuteurs
qu'il faut parler la langue pour qu'elle
continue
oui et les gens sont conscients ils le
font là est ce qu'il va y avoir une
relève par exemple je sais pas pour la
relève mais je souhaite vraiment mais je
je suis très positif quand je donne des
cours à des locuteurs de la langue qui
s'intéresse plus qu'ils sont vraiment
ravis d'apprendre de comprendre comment
fonctionne un oui est ce que s'il ya
beaucoup d'espoir oui alors vous
l'enseigné aux quatre coins du québec
mais vous allez reprendre on est à
montréal donc les cours vont reprendre
cet automne à l'université de montréal
n'est ce pas et c'est ça je peux
reprendre les cours à l'universel -7
autant et aussi pour les locuteurs de la
basse côte nord est de la côte nord
voilà continuez votre mission yvette
molène merci beaucoup jenisch comme et
un benzema roumanie
alors on se tourne vers mot clark et là
on change complètement de langue on s'en
va vers le cri des plaines avec une des
pièces que nous interprète vauclare qui
sont musiciens
[Musique]
c'est dans ce round qui se tenait au
atos carennac et
un champ centre qui est à souligner la
persévérance leur résilience
et l'importance et la valeur de nos
chances de nos professions et de nos
histoires qu'il faut un se jouer
ensemble et et danser pour remercier la
mairie pour remercier nos ancêtres pour
remercier tous les êtres vivants et pour
remercier les cats aliments
[Musique]
mais
oh
alors
et
et on
walayo
ouais ouais
[Musique]
ce cas
avec la nati
quand
[Musique]
à lima
les mojitos dix matches joués
mama
au total
le tas
[Musique]
mais bon
gaia
afin que tu y as
[Musique]
et
ah ouais
mais
[Musique]
hu
mais on
[Musique]
ouais
m
oslo
à tort
[Musique]
et quant à tchita ti gars
iman
tesquet crémant du titan
ah ouais
qui mme hama
sitôt cette hauteur
mais thad mai
des gants
tu
les gars
tiens
[Musique]
magnifique absolument magnifique merci
mots donc on va retrouver un petit peu
plus tard au cours de cette émission
pour une autre pièce mais d'abord je me
tourne vers un politicien mais
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le politicien
qui va parler c'est l'homme qui apprend
le mot wac mark miller vont jouer
bonjour alors mark miller vous êtes un
député député libéral je vais quand même
le dire la job à bon compte oui
exactement rue marie le sud ouest ile
des soeurs fédéral bien sûr alors vous
vous êtes déplacés aujourd'hui pour
venir nous parler d'une langue que vous
apprenez mais avant je demande et
isabelle de nous parler un peu du monde
oui en fait la langue gagnant guerre à l
ai parlé au québec par 2400 personnes
dans les trois communautés on parle de
kahnawake cannes s attaquer et à quoi ça
ce n'est elle fait partie cette langue
là des langues et rocco yens tout comme
la langue wendat également et donc ses
20% de la population qui vont parler le
gagnant guerra il y a évidemment de
nombreux efforts qui vont être faits
pour sauvegarder la langue pour la
transmettre
puisque dans une même famille souvent le
grand parents vont parler la langue
gagnant guerra comme une langue
maternelle
oui et les petits enfants
malheureusement ne vont comprendre que
quelques mots monsieur miller d'abord
qu'est ce qui vous pose qu'est-ce qui
vous a poussé à rendre utile oui je
serai très franc j'ai été excessivement
nef
d'abord je faisais la tournée avec la
ministre des relations couronne
autochtone dans le temps et avec avec
plusieurs années plus tard plusieurs
chefs qui nous parlait notamment de la
menace ou langue autochtone
il fait que dans une génération si on ne
faisait pas de croix au niveau fédéral
provincial municipal
il y aurait peut-être deux ou trois
langues qui survivraient dans la
prochaine génération alors une langue
c'est la vitalité d'une langue ça se
mesure pas dans des cycles électoraux de
quatre ans ça se mesure dans des cycles
générationnel dans des mesures de 30 ans
alors ça m'a touché profondément j'ai
fait une petite réflexion j'étais dans
ce temps le président du caucus du
québec j'encourage il
j'encourage mes collègues dans les
autres provinces à parler le français
prendre des cours alors j'ai aussi
pourquoi prendre
apprendre une langue autochtone alors
j'ai dit pourquoi pas deux mois que ça
dure est facile c'est tout à fait le
contraire sinon c'est une langue
excessivement complexe excessivement
riche riche en images
oui difficile d'accès surtout pour
quelqu'un qui pète okten comme moi alors
je me suis jeté dedans et j'ai trouvé un
cours en ligne
évidemment je ne viens pas d'une
communauté je n'ai pas droit aux cours
qui sont offerts et j'ai trouvé un
groupe de personnes à six nations en
ontario qui d'offres le cours en ligne
dont brahim marco et sa fille zohra
keynes alors j'ai suivi le cours pendant
plusieurs mois et je continue à le faire
de ce jour en fait mais un cours en
ligne comme comment se déroule la
discussion parce que c'est important de
discuter quand on apprend une langue
donc c'est un challenge énorme d'abord
le penon locuteurs d'autant plus des
gens qui veulent parler à moi là dedans
mais avec moi avec mon échéant c'est un
peu débile
alors d'abord j'ai suivi un cours en
ligne et ensuite j'ai parlé à mon prof
et j'envoyais d'aidé
des mp3 ou jeu et ça marche ça marche
encore g g cuche comme un ordinateur qui
marche super lentement j'veux la
difficulté à réagir je comprend une demi
heure après ce qui s'est dit oui
évidemment comme je le soulignais tantôt
c'est une langue excessivement
difficiles complexes riches plus riches
certaine manière que l'anglais le
français et est donc pour quelqu'un qui
l'a quittée pendant deux ans et demi
comme moi je suis vraiment à mes tout
débuts
vous êtes courageux parce qu'en 2010 est
déjà au parlement canadien vous avez
parliez vous avez parlé jeudi au wat
mais on dit tout on dit maintenant
gagner de gaia vous avez parlé pendant à
peu près une minute cette année vous
avez fait un discours qui a fait quoi 17
18 minutes
incroyable donc voulu parler
suffisamment pour avoir une conversation
avec qu'à un moment je peut causer très
brièvement alors le discours que j'ai
prononcé j'ai fait beaucoup de pratique
c'est des mots qui sont excessivement
compliqué c'est une langue agglutinant
tout pâle et synthétiques ou l'énoncé
construisent d'abord avec une racine
viande on rajoute des succès comme lille
ou ce que nous disait yvette oui mais je
me pratique beaucoup alors un député qui
donne un discours tout cuisse ça prend
une certaine préparation mais moi je me
prépare pendant des heures pour donner
ce genre de zico et encore une fois
c'est des mots qui sont que j'utiliserai
pas normalement pour saluer quelqu'un
mais j'en dois beaucoup à ma femme a
fait parce que
j'ai prononcé le discours d'une minute
et je me suis dit que j'étais très fier
de moi même
tout bêtement mais le lendemain je me
suis réveillé puis ma femme m'a dit
simplement des plaines de merdy ducroux
si tu continues et pathé cours alors
j'ai continué le court et je fais à peu
près une heure par jour à bouger coûte
passivement des aînés qui parle sur la
radio mais je m'efforce de faire une
heure par jour
oui donc quand vous visitez les
communautés mauroy que vous allez à
gagner s'attaquer ou encore à gannat
wagué vous parlez en moins qu'avec les
chefs avec le grand chef
ça dépend des circonstances et des gens
qui ne parlent pas la langue
d'une certaine façon leur langue a été
enlevé brillamment consciemment de notre
gouvernement alors ça dépend ça dépend
si j'ai une certaine familiarité
j'essaie de faire une salutation en
moque je rencontre beaucoup de rami en
tant que politicien quand on rentre dans
une communauté de surcroît autochtone on
a tendance à rencontrer les politiciens
ce que ça m'a permis d'apprendre cette
langue c'est de rencontrer des gens qui
sont pas nécessairement des politiciens
c'est clair que les communautés
autochtones sont politisés
[Musique]
mais je rencontre des personnes qui sont
passionnés par leur langue beaucoup
d'aînés et je rentre comme étudiant au
lieu de rentrer comme un gros
politiciens et le résultat inespéré tout
ça mais que jeu que j'aime vraiment ce
que j'ai rencontré des amis je suis fait
des amitiés avec des personnes que je
n'aurais pas eu le privilège de
rencontrer si j'étais simple police est
en train de rentrer dans une communauté
pour faire une annonce quelqu'un on va
en parler parce que le projet de loi c
91 a été déposée évidemment vous arrivez
de la chambre des communes la comment il
va s'appliquer là savaient de quoi la
prochaine étape maintenant qu'on a dit
ok on a eu la troisième lecture bon
maintenant ça y est on se déposent
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
effectivement le challenge le plus
important de cette loi est vraiment
reconnaître de façon légale le droit à
l'enseignement le droit de parler sa
langue
l'anc qui pleure sa constance dans
presque toutes les circonstances qui ont
été raflés de donner les ressources et
les capacités à ceux qui se sont
combattus envers et contre les
politiciens pendant si longtemps pour
préserver leur langue
c'est une difficulté de taille alors
d'abord enlever la prise de décision des
politiciens établir une commission à
l'échelle nationale pour pouvoir
distribuer valoriser prioriser les
les langues bretonnes y avait vraiment
il ya des langues comme le rwanda qui
sont très très très fragilisée en train
d'être bâti et à des langues comme lino
petit e
qui sont encore dans beaucoup de vigueur
oui ils ont besoin d'être renforcées
alors essayez la raison pour laquelle il
ya eu une résistance des communautés une
aptitude à cette loi parce que c'est une
loi plusieurs invitations lancées d'ici
deux de satisfaire tous les besoins à
travers une loi elle était il y avait
des défauts dans partant de d'être
d'avoir d'abord en tant que geste
profonde réconciliation de faire
confiance à ceux qui ont se sont
combattus contre nous pour préserver ces
langues c'est un geste important de
dépolitiser le processus d'allocation
des fonds et finalement ce que je crois
que ce qui doit être le plus important
c'est de vraiment donner ces fonds là à
des gens qui ont besoin du puits de
bonifier ces fonds-là au fur et à mesure
voilà merci d'être venu aujourd'hui ses
goûts et vous êtes un bel exemple de
persévérance et surtout un bel exemple
on devrait tous intéressés une langue
autochtone on est dans un pays où on
parle des langues autochtones
on devrait les entendre plus souvent
merci bonjour merci merci voilà dans
quelques instants
on reçoit à là c'est vraiment
intéressant xavier watteau qui est notre
prochain invité alors xavier lui et
abénakis il s'installe sur le plateau
dans quelques instants
et on le disait l'abbé naquit c'est une
langue tellement fragile isabelle un peu
comme le wydad
oui tout à fait labine à qui elle sait
parler en fait la langue à odanak
jusqu'au début des années 1960
mais encore là c'était très partiels
certaines familles le parlaient est donc
absolument pas la dernière femme qui a
parlé la binah qui est décédé dans les
années 90 donc c'est déjà pour vous dire
oui et donc c'est une langue qui est en
mode survie comme plusieurs autres
langues on l'a mentionné donc au canada
et aujourd'hui c'est un linguiste non
autochtone qui enseigne la binette qu'il
a des habits neufs et ça c'est
extrêmement extrêmement et ça c'est le
cas de xavier watteau votre prof donc il
est
il est non autochtone c'est lui qui vous
en prend qui vous apprend la langue de
vos ancêtres
oui car l'enquêté
le prof quatre singles habiter ici à
montréal à odanak l'enseignement ou au
collège cuny également d'accord merci
alors on va voir si vous avez bien après
vos leçons aujourd'hui on dit bonjour
comment des biens acquis quoi je vous ai
rendu la vie fait souvent les gens vont
bondir bon jour ils vont dire oui mais
pour moi c'est comme si je te disais oh
la comprend oui c'est pas pareil
oui qu'est-ce qui vous a donné envie
vous de l'apprendre l'abbé naquit en
sachant que vous êtes un des rares
locuteurs flamand vous deviendrez un des
rares locuteurs on espère on espère je
suis rendu à 400 moins de voix que je ne
crache pas sur mais ce qui m'a donné
envie d'apprendre abénakise que c'était
quelque chose c'est quelque chose en moi
que j'ai jamais pu réellement atteint ça
nous a été enlevé il ya très longtemps
puis ça a été enlevée sans qu'on puisse
rien y faire dans le sens où je talent
et une histoire courage talent et en
nouvelle zélande de rencontrer des maris
puis à une jeune fille qui ne faisait
que réussit à réapprenez sa langue parce
qu'elle faisait partie des deux
générations perdues
puis j'ai fait le parallèle c'est la
même chose moi puis ma mère on n'a pas
appris notre langue à cause des
histoires de pensionnat où il aura fait
tout ça fait que c'est quelque chose qui
nous a été enlevé
ça nous a pas été partagé puis
maintenant on se réapproprie notre
culture qu'on a perdu tient alors
j'apprends la peña qui j'ai fait baptisé
mes enfants de façon autochtone de la
cérémonie des premiers poids et tout ça
fait que l'on retrouve ce qui nous a été
enlevé je dois mais comment allez-vous
est capable et capable de permettre
qu'elle se perpétue parce qu'être 1-2-3
locuteurs c'est pas suffisant pour
ramener à la vie une langue rare en
france quand la prochaine et il est
optimiste parce qu'il ya cinq ans
wikipedia ça disait que la langue est un
expert acté
on travaille fort pour essayer justement
de l'apprendre j'essaie de montrer des
mots à mes enfants un oeil on eut reçu
un nom abénakis justement moi je sais
que jusqu'au gpo eu encore une fois en
lien avec ce que j'ai fait auparavant
puis se décide de la prendre pour
pouvoir justement pas que ça disparaisse
pas ce que ça serait vraiment l'enfer
oui mais en plus vous avez des projets
plein la tête et entre autres la le
bâtir une application non c'est pas vrai
vous êtes sur une appli que vous avez
créé une application web un jeu peut
l'expliquer oui à nice
en fait c'est une occasion qui existent
déjà comme du hall 1 go oui ce sont je
pense qu'ils sont concurrents là ça
s'appelle même raise à quelqu'un plein
plein de langues que tu peux apprendre
justement sur son application la messe
que même reste permet de faire ce
qu'elle te permet de créer ton propre
cours de langue ça que nous on a pris le
temps toutes les notes que philippe nous
ont montré tous les mots qu'on a appris
on les a on a fait comme une banque de
données avec des catégories plus ça ça
nous permet justement son téléphone
cellulaire
on est à 2 d'apprendre des mots peut se
pratiquer je pense que c'est dans la vie
de tous les jours c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'utile parce que on est toujours
sur les gosses j'ai deux enfants je vous
ai un job à temps plein chez enseignant
au secondaire c'est pas toujours facile
de trouver le temps justement de de
s'asseoir puis d'apprendre une nouvelle
langue si complexe
justement avec la création ça
fonctionnera en bien est-ce que la binah
qui en fait la preuve l'apprentissage de
la langue ça permet de reconnecter à la
culture parce qu'il ya quelques années
j'avais fait un sondage chez les
abénakis pour la politique culturelle et
la langue était ressorti très très haut
donc c'est vraiment un sentiment qui
supporte enfant tu es ce que vous le
voyez un peu comme ça je pense que oui
je pense que je pense que si tu pars de
la langue qui peut comme embarqué dans
tout est là justement à l'été passé j'ai
commencé à un groupe de parole john mais
j'ai intégré un groupe qui on ne te
parle ça ensemble était passé ce moment
est moins d'un an qu'on joue puis on
reprend des chansons qui s'est déjà puis
on l'est on est traduit en abénakis
faculty ça nous permet justement de
reconnecter avec la culture à travers le
drame à travers la langue quand je dois
je pratique la peña qui des fois ma
grand-mère m'entends puis le dit des
fois on corrige mais j'en ai même pas
capable car connaissait des mots parce
que moi porter pour moi à ne jamais
parler
labine acquis mais elle parlait
auparavant très très longtemps il ya
oublié ce l'effet allait s'efforcer de
l'oublier t s'en souvient encore à
montreux amont des trucs que je le
jouais le rôle de l'étoile dans ses yeux
quand je suis rom quand je chante en
abénakis quand je parle avait acquis
cette extraordinaire pourrait devoir que
c'est pas disparu j'adhère émotionnel
très bon ça mais c'est formidable que ce
soit vous qui lui ramener cette mémoire
là c'est quand même incroyable
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment le fun je
suis je rends choyé de pouvoir faire ça
alors à quoi ça ressemble abénakis par
rapport aux autres langues autochtones
par rapport au rwanda par rapport au
mode par rapport à line ou encore une
fois je clame après 400 bombes à gauche
avec spa mais aussi une langue à but
c'est pas mal ce que vous avez dit
auparavant on rajoute des trucs avant et
après que c'est comme pour dire je
pensais pour dire de mon abeilles ces
symboles ont même salza c'est qu'en fait
ça par noir rayé blageon nati qui volent
accessible et intuitif qui dit oui puis
sinon
et
oui sinon c'est animé unanime est
également similaire de même ok alors là
avec vos 400 mo vous allez est ce que
philippe charland qui est donc un
autochtone qui enseigne la peña qui a
beaucoup plus de mots lui dans sa
sacoche là et de pouvoir vous enseigner
la langue lui capable justement ateliers
de conversation l'eau à 100 % oui il le
ça fait longtemps longtemps qu ils pas
aux petits c'est le prof de beynac et je
pense qu'ils s'y nicher ladd a également
fait que dans le sens où il fait ça tous
les jours d'audience en héros les
joueurs qui ont énormément fier c'est
sûr que je conseille à prend des cours
avec lui mais mon but c'est de jour
peut-être pouvoir moi même dans les
échos c'est il l'apprendra mes enfants
étant prof moi même je serai dans sa
jungle de l'enseigné fait que j'ai fait
justement je passais mes élèves à
l'école louis riel
à montréal c'est da don à vauréal
je prends parfois du temps dans mes co
pour apprendre aux élèves la vina qui
n'ont pas de choix sont pas les leurs
pour 60 minutes pas que technique
mais c'est ça je me permet justement de
donner des petits qu'aux des cours de
langue puis son super intéressé pour les
trous sa valeur
voilà bah je vous souhaite un bon été
parce que là les classes sont terminées
dont vous avez congé avez-vous congé
d'abéné qui pour l'été tous les jours je
me sens mal parce que je fais pas une
heure par jour
comme un mauvais débat va mais là j'aime
au sujet merci beaucoup vous aviez
xavier owada journée et on va écouter le
prochain vox pop on va les voir si les
gens savent qu'on parle abénakis au
québec
jack coup thibout quoique d'être comme
ça c'est ça sera et deux caches pour
être peut-être ottawa je dirais
chicoutimi voilà bon ben moi j'en
connais moins quelques-unes sur la
montérégie parce que justement kahnawake
yao k you can et s'attaquer voilà c'est
mon répertoire la montée je cherche très
longtemps personne n'a mentionné les
villages du nunavik
d'où proviennent autres invités mélodie
du plessis van jour mélodies alors
mélodie vous êtes une inouk
oui effectivement et dont vous parlez
linou petit tout
oui tout à fait mais ils ont appris
merlin oui vous auriez pu en fait non au
nunavik on ne parle que l'hymne outil
tout on ne parle pas des autres
dialectes inouk n'ont effectivement
exactement donc il ya la grande lan qui
s'appelle l'inouk tout est à l'intérieur
il ya plusieurs dialectes dont
l'inimitié tout et vous les connaissez
tous isabelle oui bah en fait je vais
passer les prononcer au canada il ya
quand même 40 mille personnes qui
parlent link est en fait d'une petite
haut de ses trente six mille personnes
sur 40000 puisqu'il ya plusieurs
dialectes
on parle de cami cap dialecte principaux
au canada est bon comme les langues
n'ont pas de frontières ça s'étend au
groenland notamment donc on pourrait
parler de 6 dialecte dans le monde donc
c'est quand même une langue importante
et et voilà est donc bien heureuse de
vous avoir quitté aujourd'hui merci de
m'avoir vous mélodie vous parlez d'une
petite août mais ce que vous comprenez
les autres dialectes un nom les
le plus proche des halles est qu'on peut
comprendre nous nous n'avez que c'est le
nunavut sont assez proches quand même
d'accord dont les résidants du nunavut
oui c'est ce corps les autres là la scop
legros à l'impôt tout à fait oui vous
êtes métis et donc de vos parents mais
c'est votre mère qui est qui j -louis
nook et elle vous a appris la langue dès
la naissance
tout à fait j'ai grandi à accous l'iveco
situé au grand nord du québec
oui et la langue inuit est encore une
langue dominante donc gelé a pris non
seulement de ma mère mais du village
également oui français de mon père et de
l'école et l'anglais de mes deux
parrains qui se parler en anglais alors
vous l'avez dit la langue est encore
très vivante
oui et elle fait partie d'ailleurs on
disait en est la preuve d'entrée de jeu
la plus parlée mais est-elle en danger
quand même si on ne fait rien en ce
moment oui ça va être bientôt mais je
sais que j'ai plusieurs
j'ai plusieurs amis des collègues de
travail qui veulent trouver un moyen
pour le garder et c'est d'ailleurs c'est
important de traduire
n'importe quel document à une enquête
est également comme ça on va pouvoir
continuer de les réécrire à l'école et
au travail
est ce ce que vous faites en fait dans
la vie puisque vous êtes interprète et
vous êtes également traductrice
quand on vous demande de travailler avec
la langue et nous petits tout qu'est ce
qu'on vous demande bien souvent des
changements oui des documents officiels
ou et
même si c'est juste une petite affiche
de créatures à une plutôt comme ça on va
chercher tout le monde le plus possible
donc oui effectivement ça fait déjà
plusieurs années que je traduis il ya de
plus en plus 18
à montréal ils sont présents à travers
la ville est ce qu'on offre des services
dans leur langue
ici à montréal ça dépend il ya des il ya
des organisations qui le sont
effectivement la langue qui nous était
offert parmi les travailleurs inuit mai
oui de plus en plus on ouvre des
organisations comment fonctionne la
longue ou et c'est une très bonne
question on me dit souvent que certains
impôts a rien qu'on connaît déjà les
autres langues autochtones ou non non
plus un pot à de l'asiatique bien biais
non plus sauf peut-être un petit peu
long le nord de la sibérie la mongolie
où les reconnaître c'est ce que lévis
isabelle un oui c'est ça oui
sinon bien souvent un monde englouti
toutes vos une phrase en france et fixés
ça peut être une longue langue l'on a
parlé et l'on a traduit parfois alors
c'est un peu comme les autres langues
autochtones très descriptive
c'est tout à fait ok allons-y avec un
exemple moi j'ai besoin de visualiser la
caisse que je pourrai houllier cll la
table la table we want you stop la table
en force avec ce truc table en une ou
plutôt que ce serait sa salle en réalité
veut dire le devin n'y a pas de mots
autre que ça donc c'est juste pour vous
donner un exemple que l'inaptitude s'est
pas vraiment des mots individuel c'est
une description et c'est pour ça que
quand on traduit une phrase défaut il
faut une deuxième phrase en français
pour le mettre pour le traduire en une
petite route donc
ouais et est ce que c'est vrai que il y
aurait une cinquantaine de mot pour
parler de la neige dans votre langue que
ces unions
c'est une réalité et je ne les connais
pas tous
selon la sorte de neige neige sèche
neige humide
oui ailleurs la neige qui tombe un ya la
neige qui est rendu au sol de la neige
molle la neige dure la neige en dessous
de la neige 2 qui comme des petites
boules pour ça aussi ça finit plus est
ce que c'est une langue qui continue à
évoluer avec les changements climatiques
j'imagine que le pergélisol va faire
apparaître des choses il va leur falloir
leur trouver des noms assez ce qu'on va
trouver
c'est une bonne question mais je pense
que oui je pense qu'il ya déjà même un
groupe d'ennemis qui se rassemblent pour
trouver une nouvelle description avec ce
qui nous arrive également les termes
qu'on n'a jamais utilisé les termes
scientifiques entre eux oui oui ça
existait pas il ya 200 ans
mais aujourd'hui il faut trouver un
moyen pour les traduire oui alors on en
invente pour nos téléspectateurs à
l'ecoute où peut-on aller lire de lino
petit tout voir de ligne petit tout
où est-ce qu'on pourrait voir ce je
pense que je peux dire sur google oui
vous allez je sais à google et lino
petite audi va voir plein plein plein
plein à l'infini qu'on peut retrouver
comme exemple oui ouais la cour me que
la communauté ici la cour milk merci
beaucoup
on va retourner dans la rue on va aller
voir si les gens connaissent bien la
langue est un outil tout
de plus ce qu'ils sont et au québec
80 et est ce que c'est une honte
de la gamme dacia
d'où ce qui est la langue maroc je sais
qu'il ya une longue de cris je pense
qu'il part innues au nord il ya eu des
petites haies en avait je parlais dans
la tête rousse d'iroquois peut-être une
amérindiens et peut-être impôts aux
hurons et ceux-là ça sert vraiment à ma
petite histoire là quand j'ai étudié
l'histoire du canada
[Musique]
tadjike matin
je ne trime à ce rythme ce haut
diplomate
lointain dévié
atta
sur quoi ça
malgré ce nom
parce que ça
quoi
et là
de faire ça m'a
la loi dalo
ma
shaw est le meilleur
c'est ma
mega passé
m
[Musique]
avant
et je tenais là
des messages
la prochaine super coup de crosse
dépasse père
la patrie
avec internet
[Musique]
mais me ward texte b
ça va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais la pharma
roi des deux familles
est joué
[Musique]
je mets
c'est le mal
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh et
61 euros
la famille
les odeurs
et est ce que vous connaissez mon de
vélo capitaux
non je suis gay plusieurs villes au
québec qui ont des origines la docteure
je pourrai pas les citer les nombreuses
c'est gros on a aimé oui c'est un mois
qu'il s'appelle philippe meyer c'est le
directeur général de montréal autochtone
et à montréal autochtones on n'apprend
pas juste le mowat mais on apprend
plusieurs langues autochtones alors si
vous avez envie de suivre des cours de
toc toc ça se passe à montréal
autochtone philippe meyer qui
connaissait les réponses à un quizz
qu'on a lancé donc combien langues
autochtones il disait 60 soit 60 70 11
langues autochtones au québec dont la
tika mec alors parlez nous de la tic
avec la tika mais quand on dit que c'est
la langue la plus vivante au canada
alors ce n'est pas rien comme titre on
sait qu'il ya trois communauté attikamek
au québec
we want shimano à nos badges one
principalement dans le nord de la
mauricie et dans les hauteurs de
lanaudière 95% des attikameks parle la
langue du québec
et si on regarde au niveau des
communautés dans les communautés ça
frôle les 100%
d'ailleurs plusieurs années on sont
unilingues en langue atikamekw et la
même chose pour des très jeunes enfants
avant qu'ils puissent avoir accès à
l'école comment est ce qu'on fait pour
affirmer que la langue attikameks est la
langue la plus vigoureuse au canada mais
en fait c'est que la moyenne des
locuteurs c'est de 21 ans
alors si on compare avec la langue à ida
par exemple ses 65 ans donc on sait que
c'est une langue qui est très vigoureux
oui alors nous allons parler de la
langue attikameks avec 6 bis flamand je
le précise tout de suite son nom s'écrit
s i pé i et se prononce s i b i see by
flamand bonjour vice-chef conseil des
attikameks de manouane la langue vous la
parler tous les jours chez vous je le
parle à tous les jours à la maison avec
mes parent avec mes neveux et nièces mon
frère et ma soeur est avec toi les gens
de la communauté et isabelle a raison
c'est une langue très parler une langue
dont on prend soin c'est une langue qui
est très riche qui est très axé sur le
territoire
sur la langue qui provient du territoire
même si aujourd'hui on vit dans la
communauté
il ya l'aspect du territoire qui est
toujours présente
est ce que le fait de rester dans son
territoire dans sa communauté est ce que
ça permet de sauvegarder la langue ou
est ce que comme pour toutes les langues
autochtones
le passage dans les pensionnats
évidemment à fait qu'elle s'est perdu
dans des familles de l'allant cadcam à
qui parler dans trois communautés
oui qui est assez isolée c'est à manawan
idem au réal mais les autres sont
beaucoup plus isolé oui oui c'est à la
fois une bonne chose parce que ça
permette de préserver cette langue ça
permet aussi de continuer à parler à
pratiquer notre notre identité
culturelle aussi est-ce que vous parlez
le même attikameks entre les trois
communautés où il ya des différences
c'est le même a dit qu'un mec me
indifférence au niveau de l'accès de
l'ex ans d'accord mais pas au niveau des
mots non vous utilisez les mêmes mots la
langue attikameks combien de mots dans
la langue attikameks il ya beaucoup de
monde comme il ya beaucoup d'activités
je pense qu'il ya 2 165 activités
attikameks ans environ qu'est ce que
vous appelez des activités les activités
comme les pratiques que le mode de vie
avec marco aurelio kuyt mais c'est une
recherche qui a été menée il ya quelques
années puis a été sélectionné environ 2
165 activités en lien avec le territoire
et toute cette l'enclos compare ça vient
ça provient de ses activités là alors
allons-y avec des exemples concrets
par exemple je sais pas je je pars à la
chasse parlons du monde de la chasse par
exemple convier à la chasse aux jo ce
calme mais à d'oscar mais c'était pour
la trappe
sinon pour aller à la chasse à lorient
ces mots scan pour
la chasse à l'orignal et ça veut dire
littéralement chasse à l'orignal oui
c'est comme on fait pas parler des idées
et des actions faire parler d'eux de ce
qu'on fait de ce conte comment je
pourrais dire sur lui son image et ben
on agit c'est une action mais je sais
comment on pourrait dire ça c'est une
action mais c'est pas nécessairement
l'action qu'on définit et à l'écrit
qu'est ce qu'il en est de l'alphabet on
n'a pas 26 lettres comme on a en
français comment commence ya quinze
lettres de l'alphabet noms dont je peux
les citer
ça fait longtemps qu'on fait des quais
sécher tes mènerait et ouais il ya une
spécificité d'en utiliser du camaq c'est
à la lueur la lettre au père qui t'a
s'est prononcée qu'en qu'on ne parle oui
oui
puis le thym le tc si c'est une autre
spécificité de la langue atikamekw
quelle langue vous avez quelle lettre
vous avez laissé tomber
par exemple le w ça n'existe pas ah ben
oui attikameks il ya déjà un w danticat
mec
le z où je sais pas ben y'a pas le z
dinde à la lente mais c'est une arme
l'utilisation de la fab et comme on
connaît mais on papote toutes les
alphabets n'existe alors comme
d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans les autres
langues et des non autochtones qui
s'intéressent à la sauvegarde de latika
mais qui en a un qui vit à man one c'est
un prof à l'école secondaire de manouane
il s'appelle luc matin et lui a décidé
de se servir de l'outil wikipédia pour
faire revivre la langue parlée moison
oui c'est d'un cadre d'un projet avec
une étudiante allemande qui était venu à
manawan pour les femmes les recherches
notamment dans le tourisme dans le
torrent spi sur l'utilisation de la
banque attica mac puis à partir de cire
chercheurs y ont développé une forme une
comme un logiciel millions utilisés
wikipedia wii ware pouvoir développer la
langue atikamekw caporaliser mais aussi
pour préserver et améliorer pour
améliorer mais amener la langue
atikamekw du territoire utilisés dans
des territoires comme on a personne dans
l'internet
adacore oui oui alors vous êtes le vice
chef
est-ce que déjà au conseil de bande ont
fait on fait des efforts qu est ce qu on
fait comme effort pour sauvegarder la
langue pour permettre qu'elles soient
transmises bien là quand il ya les
rédactions des politiques c'est autant
français qui se font mais la traduction
du québec entend de de traduire les
politiques qu'on qu'on adopte pour
attikameks ise mais c'est vraiment
difficile parce qu'il ya des concepts
des mots qui quirky apport dans notre
l'encré
puis il faut réfléchir il faut il faut
aller voir des années pour qu'on puisse
trouver le sens des mots qu'on veut
mettre dans nos politiques notamment
on a fait faire traduire le code
d'éthique des élus attikamek de manawan
qui c'était une belle exercice de de
faire la traduction parce que ça permet
aussi de de revaloriser notre lac mais
aussi de se réapproprier des outils les
instruments qui existent sur le plan
politique oui et qu'est ce qu'un ordi à
dans les écoles en fait comment est ce
que la langue et les transmise à l'école
dans les programmes d'enseignement
oui depuis 90 ans environ il ya eu un
programme bilingue et qui s'appelle
d'argentan
dans les années 80 on a six ans
seulement le français mais en 92 qui a
vu un changement dans les trois
communautés atikamekw
ils y ont développé des programmes à
l'anc attikameks ça disait un dia
nisation des programmes mais c'est a
plus cette réduction des programmes
provincial dans la langue attikameks
d'accord puis ça vient aider dans la la
préservation de la langue il a eu une
dernière question parce que radio canada
à modifier sa politique dans l'écriture
du mot attikameks donc le service de
linguistique de radio canada a décidé
maintenant d'écrire attikameks non plus
avec deux t1 cas pas de w à la fin donc
maintenant il ne reste qu'un t il y à la
toute fin 1 15 et 1 w pourquoi est ce
que c'est important d'avoir fait ce
changement pour vous c'est important
parce que ça permet de préserver de
garde et qui a une logique une écriture
sur la nomination attikameks sur les
mots oui mais dans ce cas mais qu'il ya
aussi nos réseaux il ya une politique a
été adoptée au sein du conseil de la
nation atikamekw où on doit ajouter
qu'on parle des attikameks on parle des
attikameks nos régions si les deux mois
semble d'accord mais encore beaucoup de
choses à apprendre à la merci beaucoup
siby flamand merci nous aide aux
déplacés de manouane aujourd'hui pour
venir nous rencontrer
merci bonne journée autochtone à tout le
monde puis à la merci alors isabelle on
va recevoir mode en un instant mots qui
nous a interprété deux pièces on va
parler avec elle d'une langue qui
s'appelle le cri des plaines il avait
pris des notes sur le cri des plaines
vous la connaissez maintenant cette
langue
oui davantage puisque bon le cri des
plaines évidemment le mot le dit ça ne
se parlent pas au québec
c'est une langue qui fait aussi partie
de la famille algonquienne en fait c'est
une c'est la famille linguistique la
plus importants des onze famille
linguistique autochtones au canada est
donc cette langue elle est surtout
parler
en alberta en saskatchewan et un peu
également au manitoba et l'alphabet
syllabique cris des plaines ne comptait
que 12 caractères au départ et ça a été
modifié et adapté à travers le temps et
en 2016 environ 96 mille personnes
déclarées par les le cri est donc près
de 6000 personnes parlaient le cri des
plaines
alors mme auclair bonjour tensei c'est
drôle parce que je viens de faire une
entrevue il ya juste quelques jours oui
et en ayant wayne on crie en du temps c
est ça c'est comment on dit allô oui bon
je dis ça va oui
[ __ ] tu sais c'est aussi aux mots à
nos petits trucs qui aimait élève m'a
enseigné que temps c'est en octobre que
veut dire on va danser alors bonjour
validant ces voix là voilà temps c'est
en ces mots avant d'aller plus loin
présentez-vous notre votre musiciens
avec qu'ils appuient voilà lui je suis
ici avec mon ami mon ami go amorino
vazquez et mourinho peut lui interdire
douville bien au hockey à leurs proches
aux nouvelles ou de maxiq du mexique
dans votre langue à vous c'est
l'espagnol oui là notre langue coloniale
oui mais selena watts pour et malina
watts et notre langue de l'enquêté je
pense que plus de mille milliards de
personnes que des parle d'un milliard
millions millions ou milliers peut-être
un sas est plus juste no one woman show
un point 3 millions oui c'est beaucoup
et comment dit-on bonjour dans votre
langue
c'est vraiment seulement que je dois
reconnaître que la langue espagnole
c'est pas la langue
oui vraiment régional de 7,2 cette part
de cette partie de mexique il ya de
beaux coups de lance à potec mixtèque
tortona cas
huawei voilà je suis pas une experte pas
fan de ce mal de maya il ya 20 18 et le
cri des plaines il y en a un cri des
plaines où il ya plusieurs dialectes
selon conviennent de l'alberta ou
conviennent d'une autre province oui
mais là directs créés de plaine que
j'apprends c'est là d un acte y donc
c'est intéressant parce que on a un côté
seppi qui parle de le attikameks et
attikameks est tellement semblables mais
cela dit halak terre est le nôtre c'est
le dialecte y met au nord de
saskatchewan et en alberta c'est la
dialectique th
donc je pourrais dire oui j'étais pas
préparé pour une entreprise et j'avais
pensé qu'on va je chantais nobel chance
c'est toujours un plaisir de vous parler
sa mère elle et elle écrit d'une horde
est donc l'année passée on a écrit une
chanson pour une réelle et pour en art
et les cris de nô et leur façon de
parler c'est tellement plus avec l'état
donc on a dit qu'il est nos couettes un
nom commun o'shea nissan et côté ni pays
qui capitaux dont anita nan ça c'est au
nord depuis ni annan ça c'est avec le
dialecte de plaine ce cri oui vous me
l'avez vous appris le cri le cri des
plaines quand vous étiez tout jeune à la
maison non pas du tout je suis métisse
avec des origines cris française et donc
c'était juste ça fait sept ans
maintenant et c'était un de mes tantes
chaire de randa qui est une autre grande
artillerie amétis cris puis en a parlé
puis à la démo c'est peut-être un bon
moment pour toi d'apprendre la langue et
quel moment aussi d'apprendre la langue
c'est d'écrire les chansons
donc j'avais revenue avec elle puis avec
joseph qui ça fait sept ans qu'on a
commencé un projet pour écrire les
chansons en relation avec la terre en
relation avec la mère terre avec la cire
communie avec les aînés dans les
endroits différents donc on a commencé à
4 fois à cappelle valais ou mais on sait
bien où ils ont à faire
le cheminement de manitoba jusqu'à
l'alberta ils ont traversé quatre points
puis l année prochaine en a fait et
l'île de toronto donc sur le bord du lac
ontario puis à l'année passée on a fait
dans le territoire de joseph donc avec
les aînés à de lui on a fait le temps de
sudation et donc on a mais les chansons
dans les territoires différentes pour
voir qu'est ce que ça donne
puis la chanson qu'on a chanté
aujourd'hui c'était une chanson qu'on
ait faite sur le bord du lac ontario et
on était en train de mettre faire le
tombeau de chanter les chansons pour la
première fois et les oiseaux toner a
vraiment commencé un grand d'orchestre
juste à travers nous donc on a 10 s
était en arrêt par les oiseaux tonneaux
donc c'est une chanson avec beaucoup de
force et avec beaucoup de capacités de
nettoyer et d'amener la bénédiction et
dans cet étang de l'année aussi c'est
important parce que c'est le temps de
l'année des oiseaux tonnerre avec la
pluie avait calé hinault tout le
lightning thunder dézonage c'est ça oui
et ça c'était un bon moment pour
l'interpréter ouais en pleine période du
solstice d'été ouais c'est ça et donc
c'est aussi comme en voit la langue en
transformation et la langue dans le
corps comment est ce que ça pourrait
aussi être le medicine oui et pour moi
ça fait tellement aimé dessiner pour les
artistes avec lesquels je travaille
aussi
c'est vraiment une au nord de leur
apprendre la langue en chantant ensemble
ça fait un bout de temps un fait de
beaucoup de pratique beaucoup de défauts
pour comprendre ce n'est pas seulement
pour dire les mots mais pour comprendre
les histoires et qui ont laissé des
partages et puis c'est tout maintenant
pour moi aussi mais je suis dehors de
ces pays visé
c'est vraiment un jeu sûrement touché
parce que j'étais bien et nous avec
[Musique]
on vous rend la vie difficile parce que
c'est quoi votre quatrième langue là je
sais je pense que je n'ai pas très bien
merci merci merci beaucoup merci mots
alors l'été ça se passe comment pour
vous dernière question vous allez faire
quoi ou est ce qu'on peut vous entende
ou est ce qu'on peut entendre de votre
bouche la langue du cri le cri des
plaines en fait un mea 14,7 après midi
au square cabot va faire la journée
nationale des autochtones là bas puis au
début août je vais faire un grand
spectacle avec laurent volant au
cinquième salle est un jeune artiste
ainhoa scop piemme picarde et c'est dans
le cadre de l' orchestre symphonique de
montréal c'est comme un collaboration
avec trois musiciens qui je vais voyager
un peu dans l'ouest vraiment pour faire
comme un programme et jazz métis et pour
continuer la pratique on fait aussi
c'est d'amener les jeunes autochtones
solitaire à de faire les cérémonies de
fait la création la créativité avec un
donc c'est le 9 août le spectacle avec
leur envol en voile s'appelle makusham
m'a couché voilà merci merci beaucoup à
tous les deux merci nous avons à dire
qu'on est passé ces deux belles pièces
et c'est la fin de l'émission alors il
faut annoncer quand même cour que ce 21
juin la ville de montréal a pris une
décision importante c'est de renommer
une rue la rue amherst non loin de
radio-canada et on lui a donné un nom
mohawk bourg et je vais vous le dire en
réalité vous allez le voir sur les
pancartes cela est écrit à tat eu qu'à
le hand ont atteint takenne mais ça se
prononce à dagana de damgan on vous le
savez déjà ok répéter s'il vous plaît de
dacca voilà ça c'est vraiment
intéressant ça a été une belle nouvelle
aujourd'hui et puis à shukan alors à
shukan moi j'avais luxe a dit ça voulait
dire
un pont un pont alors on va vérifier oui
à yvette mullen me fait signe que oui
c'est un poncho cannes c'est un pont
donc c'est un plaisir de terminer cette
émission ici au pied donc de l'espace
culturel la chicane
merci d'avoir été avec moi aujourd'hui
plaisait ça a été un plaisir avec tous
les invités connus aujourd'hui pour
parler des langues autochtones en date
ont dit comment merci on dit ni roi ni
awa gnahoua et au plaisir de vous
retrouver pour une prochaine édition d'
espace autochtone en direct et bien sûr
l'été prochain 21 juin pour une autre
journée nationale des peuples
autochtones au revoir et 6
[Musique]
oh
g
[Musique]